some of what we want deep down in our
primitive unconscious threatens to be
pretty dark we may want to do no work to
steal to injure others to give way to
despair or to have sex in very taboo and
damaging ways yet most of us do very
little of this in fact we often pour our
energies into worthwhile projects and go
out of our way to try to be good and
helpful to those around us that we're
able to do this fascinated the founder
of psychoanalysis Sigmund Freud who gave
a special word this ability to put our
primitive egoistic destructive energies
to good use he called the process
sublimation in German su blew me home it
was an idea that came to Freud while he
was reading a well-known and charming
travel book the hearts journey by the
19th century poet Heinrich Heine in it
ina mentioned meeting a legendary German
surgeon called Johann Friedrich
deffenbaugh who'd been extremely selfish
and sadistic as a boy loving to cut off
the tails of stray dogs for sheer
twisted pleasure but then as an adult
had matured into a profoundly selfless
and brilliant surgeon who'd made some
pioneering discoveries in the fields of
reconstructive and plastic surgery
Freud felt that this evolution from a
person who had sadistically used a knife
to wound to one who had nobly used it to
mend could not have been a mere
coincidence and proposed that what was
at play belong to a widespread pattern
of behavior whereby an early harmful or
shocking drive gives rise to precisely
its opposite with the strength of the
negative determining the power of the
positive Freud felt that this desire for
compensation lay at the heart of many of
the greatest achievements in the arts
politics and science so a great police
detective might at an unconscious level
be defending themselves against certain
of their own illegal wishes and a
politician committed to the plight of
the poor might be sublimating an early
experience of raging greed in an essay
on leonardo da vinci an akin heights of
in hong dis leonardo da vinci freud
presented the claim that da Vinci had
been an extremely
sexually active child who had then
sublimated his sexuality into scientific
research and art as Freud putted a
forbidden desire for sexual pleasure in
this case for his mother and then other
boys had turned in da Vinci into a
hugely honorable and powerful general
urge to know the theory of sublimation
is so hopeful because there's so much
about what we all want that proves
impossible while there would be infinite
reasons for anger and sterile nihilism
Freud notes our capacity to seek
compensation and alternative
fulfillments repeatedly in his work
Freud stressed a fact which though it
sounds absurdly obvious we nevertheless
usually fail to give enough weight to
that all of us started out as babies in
that state we wanted only immediate
pleasure and satisfaction our drives in
their initial forms which are things
that couldn't work out for us
and that had to be painfully surrendered
we believe that if we didn't get all we
wanted at once it would be a catastrophe
and we would die this kind of thinking
explains the shrieking and wailing of
infants in a tantrum we thought the
world revolved just around us and we
couldn't be generous to others and yet
most of us turned into healthy adults by
managing to substitute our original
narcissistic aims for more ethical and
fruitful alternatives Freud added
soberly that we're never quite done with
sublimation we continue to be frustrated
in what we really want most often around
sex continually we encounter people we'd
love to sleep with but mustn't and yet
rather than this energy going nowhere we
have an ability to use our frustration
to power other things creative endeavors
scientific breakthroughs care for the
vulnerable in Freud's eyes
disappointment is inevitable our
longings will systematically outrun
reality but sublimation remains the one
hugely helpful option for us under its
guidance Envy can turn into effort
wounded egoism into a capacity for
gratitude and appreciation sexual
rejection into a film or a novel as
Freud soared psychoanalysis is the field
designed to help us discover how we can
use
appts more productively how we can grow
up to be not embittered or shut down but
paradoxically energized by some of our
greatest underlying sorrows the good
life isn't one where we get exactly what
we want
it's one where we find fulfilling second
bests and where we have the inner
freedom to redirect our disappointments
with maximal imagination a life where
we've learned as Freud try to show us to
sublimate well
you